bonjour vous le voyez nous sommes à
ground zero il est 8h30 à new york et
dans un peu plus d'une demi-heure new
york et l'amérique observons une minute
de silence en mémoire des 3000 morts des
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 on va
aller tout de suite à washington
retrouvez notre correspondant adrien
jaulmes ce bonjour adrien comment
l'amérique et en particulier les
autorités américaines vont commémorer
l'événement
la commémoration du
20e anniversaire
et on a
il est une sorte de cuiller à 7
on a un petit une petite
coupure de son adria si on peut remettre
des avec des oreillettes tête ça
marchera mieux
des oreillettes non c'est bon c'est
parfait on vous entend bien donc vous ne
disiez comment se passe là les
70 à
résoudre spécial cette année
une résonance spécial cette année quels
sont vos souvenirs du 11 septembre quel
est votre regard vingt ans après vous
nous posez vos questions vos
commentaires on va les partager donc
avec adria jones à washington lors
mandeville grand reporter au service
international du figaro et dominique
reynié directeur général de la fondapol
dominique vous avez
dirigé cette étude récemment remise à
jour les attentats islamistes dans le
monde
1979 2021 on va en reparler
adrien je reviens vers vous est ce que
aujourd'hui les américains sont plus
obsédés par la pandémie que par la
menace d'attentats islamistes
la pandémie a des sauts toutes les
autres produits passent sous le menace
terroriste les états unis donc totale
portant au dédale et ça se voit
particulière aux
enfants tas de noms ont démasqué ya des
bus ni pertes sont de retour plus
drastiques
ces
mesures visent
yade ex ivacs adria il ya des coupures
de il des coupures de deux sont un peu
des interruptions de son dans ce que
vous dites peut-être si vous mettez des
oreillettes peut-être qu on vous
entendra mieux je vous laisse en
récupérer je reviens sur le plateau je
reviens avec vous adrien avec avec vous
dominique et lors peut-être revenir sur
vous le souvenir que vous gardez de
cette journée du 11 septembre on va
demander justement aux internautes le
souvenir qu'ils en gardent qu'ils en ont
calé vous
les vocations qui vous revient tout de
suite à l'esprit quand on vous parle du
11 septembre 2001 alors moi 11 septembre
2001 en fait je viens de rentrer d'un
congé maternité puisque monfils nerfs
2000 et je suis depuis une semaine et je
pense je me suis fais moi qui suis
normalement par monts et par vaux j'ai
décidé de rester au desk et j'assure ce
jour-là l'édition et je pense que une
semaine après la rentrée tout va être
assez cool je vais pouvoir finalement
profiter un peu de mon enfant et je
reviens de déjeuner je mets mes pieds
sur le bureau jax l'uimm cnn et je
m'aperçois qu'on est en direct qu'une
tour vient de se crasher en fait dans la
première des tours jumelles et je suis
absolument donc il ya un commentaire de
sa fille anne se produire et j'assiste
en direct alors que des caméras ont déjà
été posées dont concis nl et en direct
alors l'impact du deuxième avion dans la
deuxième tour évidemment c'est un moment
d'émotion intense
d'effroi de grand désarroi et aussi de
c'est une petite musique le sentiment
que quelque chose de d'énormes vient de
se produire et qui va évidemment ma [ __ ]
et pendant toute cette journée où on
doit dans l'urgence en fait mon but
disaient toutes nos troupes et c'est
vrai que je me souviens qu'à la fin de
cette journée où nous sommes tous à nous
demander ce qui nous arrive est ce qui
arrive à la mairie qu'est ce qui nous
arrive qui arrive à notre monde le
figaro au terme d'une discussion arrive
à un t1 titre qui va être la nouvelle
guerre et
l'éditorial de chars lambroschini le
csars lambroschini qui est alors le chef
de service du
le rédacteur en chef en charge de
l'international et son titre c'est ben
laden le nouveau lénine et donc c'est
vrai que le figaro ce jour-là anticipe
qu on change de monde c'est à dire qu'on
est sorti de la prévert froide et on est
dans une nouvelle guerre dans un nouvel
monde avec un nouvel adversaire
idéologique pour l'occident donc on a
perçu ce basculement
très important qui d'une certaine
manière dure encore
dominique vous qui à la fois combattre
ben laden et neel et nina tragique à la
fraude à paul quels souvenirs vous avez
vous gardé de cette journée du 11
septembre il ya de fait étonnant le
premier qui marque l'incrédulité qu'on a
tous ressenti au manque d'informations
je faisais passer je tiens un jeu
président et un jury à sciences po on se
fait des étudiants et un étudiant qui
rentre dans la pièce tremblant blême et
je lui dit écoutez je pensais que cette
tragédie ne vous inquiétez pas ça va
bien se passer et que vous arrive-t-il
immédiat non mais je suis effrayé
l'aviation au palestinienne vient de
bombarder new york je veux d'écouter ça
m'étonnerait que ce que vous venez de
dire lieu donc calmez vous c'est un
effet de la panique vie il ya qu'est-ce
qu'ils avaient été lavés sexualité nous
aviez à cette époque je voyais pas la
race d'aviation palestinienne si vous
voulez alors ils n'avaient pas
l'information il a vu au moins un mort
cinq formations moi j'ai fait passer
mais euros puis bout de 1h j'allais voir
quand même ça me trottait dans la tête
ce qui s'était passé j'ai découvert et
le deuxième souvenir très très associé
on avait chez nous à la maison
l'étudiant américain qui ont hébergé et
qui le soir même bien sûr un vu ça en
étant effrayer elie reparti chez lui à
new york en décembre dans le même avion
que richard red
richards aide qui était un des
terroristes enfin quelqu'un qui voulait
attaquer justement les états unis avec
des explosifs dans ses chaussures et ils
étaient dans cet avion cet étudiant et
il a assisté à l'arrestation de de
richard eyre et jared après avoir eu en
france à paris le spectacle du 11
septembre quand même beaucoup et ce
sentiment ni l'espèce voilà de
d'incroyables présence du terrorisme à
partir de là ce que la suite bien sûr
n'a fait que confirmer
il y a dans les
différentes dans les différents articles
que l'on vous que l'on peut lire
aujourd'hui un espèce de désenchantement
par rapport
à cet événement un espèce de thon qui
est finalement à quoi ça à quoi ça a
servi
est ce que finalement c'est un c'est un
état d'esprit que vous comprenez je vous
pose d'abord la question à vous lors
puisque vous parlez quand même deux
débâcles géopolitique pour les états
unis
dans l'interview vous faites du
professeur joshua münchen que je
recommande bien sûr à nos lecteurs que
je recommande aussi donc oui
effectivement le désenchantement
il est là depuis déjà des années c'est à
dire que les américains mais mais mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a une vous voulez une
rencontre entre cette date anniversaire
des 20 ans du 11 septembre et
l'organisme l'orchestration dur très
chaotique je dirais dans le chaos
l'incompétence et la précipitation qui
orchestrait par l'administration maiden
quelque chose qui ne peut que frapper
les imaginations et qui illustre d'une
certaine manière
ce conte ce qu'il faut bien appeler une
forme d'échec de se contenter les
américains pendant ses vingt ans alors
ce qui est vrai c'est que
l'idée d'un retrait américain en lui
même n'est pas quelque chose qui est
critiqué par une grande majorité des
américains et par d'ailleurs beaucoup de
commentateurs dans moi même je suis
c'est à dire que l'idée de guerre qui ne
finissent jamais bien sûr est quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui apparaît
complètement
critiquable mais c'est la manière dont
ces événements se produisent et le
retour symbolique finalement des
talibans au pouvoir qui provoque la un
malaise profond au sein de l'occident
l'idée que finalement à quoi ont servi
ces vingt ans à quoi ont servi les trois
trillions de dollars qui ont été
déversées sur l'afghanistan pendant
pendant 20 ans les milliers de morts
américains les dizaines de milliers de
soldats traumatisés atteint 2 qui sont
hantés par la guerre à laquelle ils ont
participé
donc il ya des dégâts à invisible dans
la société américaine de cette guerre
dont on parle moins que des morts eux
mêmes et cette idée que finalement le
l'afghanistan peut redevenir une
plateforme aussi où pourrait pourrait
ressurgir le terrorisme islamique
puisqu'on sait aujourd'hui que la l'état
islamique est présent en afghanistan ils
ont perpétré dans les derniers jours du
retrait d'un attentat spectaculaire
contre les américains qui a d'ailleurs
fait 13 morts parmi les soldats donc
effectivement beaucoup de raisons de
fêter ce vingtième anniversaire dans le
désenchantement
dans le désenchantement tous les cas les
images ne montrent pas en ce moment à
new york on a vu l'ancien président
barack obama et on voit joe biden donc
ici à
ground zero main sur le coeur on va
retrouver
adrien jaulmes washington adrien c'était
la question qu'on se posait tout à
l'heure on voit tous ces gens masqués
commémorer cet événement est la question
effectivement qu'on se poser tout à
l'heure c'était est ce que précisément
les américains sont plus aujourd'hui
obsédé par cette nouvelle réalité qui
est la pandémie que par la peur d'un
attentat islamiste comme ceux du type de
ce qu'ont été les attentats du 11
septembre
oui ça me paraît 10 dont on le voit ça
puis s'en portent des masques les gens
ont fait à faire face à un autre et le
virus violemment frappé cette petite
fille et qui est une menace beaucoup
plus exalté le
souvenir du nahd d'être un terroriste a
pas eu de galles à sa mort
c'est
une autre une autre question qui ceux
qui se posent
quand on regarde l'interview de joshua
mitchell lors sait
puisqu'on veut il est 14h45 donc on est
au moment même où justement un des
premier avion percute la tour nord et
donc
ce premier ce premier avion qui va vous
est signalé par sept par cet étudiant
qui pensent que c'est un avion
palestiniens dominique jeu chemin
mitchell dit
que c'est un traumatisme pour la psyché
américaine en général et en particulier
pour ceux qu'on appelle les néolibéraux
parce que le world trade center c'est un
lieu particulier c'est pas simplement un
lieu américain c'est un lieu mondial
tout à fait il ya plusieurs éléments là
qui est qui sont les miens souligné par
john mitchell c'est le premier c'est là
le traumatisme bien sûr de tout d'un
coup du territoire frappé du territoire
que les américains jugent est inviolable
c'est vrai que c'est la première fois
dans leur histoire que les états unis
sont frappés par un attentat qui reste
le plus grand attentat terroriste c'est
probablement de l'histoire et donc
c'est un traumatisme énorme les etats
unis se sont toujours pensé comme un
monde en soi un
comment dire un monde qui se suffisait à
lui même et qui d'ailleurs pendant dès
le premier siècle ou les premières
décennies
n'estimez pas de voir se mêler des
affaires du monde et pensez pouvoir
telle une cité scintillante être un
modèle mais sans s'impliquer dans les
tumultes de la vieille europe notamment
qu' elle lui paraissait entaché d'une
faute particulière parce qu'elles
étaient mêlés justement à une
implication dans le tumulte du monde et
donc yaya cet élément-là n'oublions pas
que pearl harbor qui l'autre moment où
ils sont frappés au coeur ça se passe
quand même à 4000 km d du territoire
américain enfin du coeur du territoire
américain et donc et puis en plus comme
vous le dit
effectivement vincent c'est le lieu
symbolique puisque c'est pas seulement
le corps new york entend la finance mais
c'est aussi le symbole en fait de
l'amérique de sa puissance de ce
prospérité de ses valeurs et c est donc
ça c'est la première chose qui le dit
mais ce qui dit aussi à mon avis qui est
très intéressant c'est que les états
unis étaient plongées au moment où cette
affaire éclate où ils sont frappés d'une
sorte de syndrome de free triomphalisme
naïve qui était le triomphe aline de
l'après guerre froide en fait on est au
sommet l'hyperpuissance mairie de la
colorisé par hubert védrine tout à fait
ce que je devais drine parle de
l'hyperpuissance exactement ces années
là c'est les années les années clinton
si vous voulez où justement l'émergence
d' aussi de la de l'internet du
numérique etc et donc ils se sentent
invincibles ils pensent que leur modèle
qu'on est l'idéologie qui prévaut c'est
la modernisation
formidable qui va gagner le monde entier
qui va déboucher sur la démocratisation
est au fond le modèle américain est le
modèle qui va prévaloir partout et tout
d'un coup ils sont ramenés au réel par
set cette frappe qui est menée par des
gens qui se transforme en bombe dont pas
du tout avec des moyens sophistiqués
ça veut dire que la technique la
sophistication de la puissance militaire
américaine ne peut rien contre des
hommes qui semble venir du moyen âge
mais qui skie qui décident de de frapper
cette amérique dans tous ses aspects et
et c'est l'idée aussi que finalement le
monde revient à la loi de la religion et
qu'on croyait complètement
défaite et 10 ont dépassé et d'aider et
de d'instinct tribaux donc on est
complètement pas on est on est pas du
tout dans la fin de l'histoire vous
pouviez le mans cette année dans le choc
des civilisations de huntington c'était
la question je vais vous poser dominique
c'était que à l'époque
le grand livre qui a été la référence
pendant les années 90 c'était le livre
de francis fukuyama qui
paraît au lendemain de la chute du mur
de berlin la fin de la guerre froide et
qui signe ce qu'on appelle la fin de
l'histoire et l'avènement du modèle
américain est ce que là à ce moment là
on vit justement la fin n'ont pas de
l'histoire mais la fin de la thèse de
fukuyama moi je crois pas que vous ayez
en main et écrit ça mélangé une
divergence l'incorporation de son livre
est donc ce serait pas l'objet de
développer mais en tout cas c'est
certain que ça vient de cet événement
vient briser
un moment
de complétude en quelque sorte où la cie
la société américaine et à travers elle
la civilisation occidentale
dans le prolongement de l'effondrement
du bloc soviétique
et
l'entrée de la chine dans le système
libéral commercial en tout cas sur le
plan économique tout ceci marque et une
fin de cycle est plutôt sous les
couleurs de l'occident en particulier
des états unis et c'est une c'est une
surprise pour commencer mais d'une
certaine manière
la plus grande surprise il me semble
elle vient enfin le plus grand show qui
vient du retour des taliban ensuite
vingt ans plus tard parce qu'on pouvait
bien imaginer un drame pareil
ce qu'il a déclenchée en le sait on va
pas le rappeler mais ce qui a déclenché
du côté des américains en tout cas de la
plupart c'est la certitude qu'on peut
répliquer punir et affirmer cette
fois-ci par le bâton
contre ceux qui décidément ne veulent
pas accepter cette cette nouvelle ère là
là là le signe de la victoire vingt ans
plus tard là par contre il ne reste
apparemment plus rien je pense qu'on est
excessif quand on dit qu'il ne reste
plus rien mais c'est pas le sujet de
votre débarrassant au donc je vais pas
développer ce point je pense qu'il s'est
passé beaucoup de choses à 20 en
afghanistan et ça va rendre plus
difficile la tâche des talibans et c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais malgré tout non
mais vous répondez à une des questions
que je me pose depuis la chute de kaboul
donc vous pensez que ce qui est que les
talibans ont remporté une manche mx est
peut-être plus compliqué
vingt ans dans un autre modèle avec des
perspectives tout à fait différente qui
ont fécondé quelque chose qui ne va pas
c'est tout fait comme ça en tout cas
c'est ce qui ressort effectivement quand
on lit le reportage de l'envoyée
spéciale du figaro
et du skieur magazine sur place marion
ben sûr justement les difficultés l'état
d'anarchie qui règne actuellement à
kaboul il est
8h51 à new york et vous le voyez on va
vous laissez le vivre d'ailleurs
quelques secondes
à commencer la lecture des noms des
victimes du world du las des attaques
contre le world trade center
c'est on va y revenir dans un instant
mais effectivement
quelque chose que l'on voit chaque année
au moment du 11 septembre
[Musique]
hayward joseph pas
des
[Musique]
délits mineurs
dennis hopper jack
dvd aljure
normandie là c'est je le disais juste
avant qu'on écoute c'est quelque chose
que l'on voit
donc chaque année maintenant depuis le
11 septembre 2002 depuis le premier
anniversaire du 11 septembre
oui enfin moi je me souviens
particulièrement de dialyse en fait
quand effectivement il y avait eu une
cérémonie extrêmement solennelle et
j'étais correspondante à l'époque est
effectivement barack obama et étaient
présents il y avait juste ou sept tous
ces discours les uns après les autres
avec les noms et non c'est donc c'est
vrai qu'il ya une vraie volonté de
rendre hommage aux victimes et de garder
le souvenir en fait des gens qui ont
péri dans ces terribles attentats c'est
vrai que pendant toutes ces années mais
moi j'avais fait qu à pas mal de
reportages à l'occasion du 10ème
anniversaire ce qui était frappant c'est
à quel point c'était l'intensité des
sentiments des plaies qui sera qui sera
vive et qui s'ouvrait quand on parlait
avec les new yorkais où les d'ailleurs
les habitants de washington etc sur tous
ces sujets et toutes les traces qui
restent encore de ses souffrances avec
par exemple tous et vous savez les
fâcheries pense pas tous ces gens qui
ont répondu à l'appel ougandais
d'ailleurs été forcé de répondre à
l'appel ou certains n'ont pas on ne leur
a pas demandé leur avis vous avez eu des
chauffeurs de bus du new jersey par
exemple qui ont été forcés pendant des
mois en fait de travailler dans les
décombres qui ont après subi des menus
des maladies absolument terrible
pour avoir respiré toutes ses
dires poussière extrêmement toxique en
fait de ce thème amoncellement de ruiner
c'est vrai que on a oublié que ça a duré
tellement longtemps en fait que new york
arrêt a été en son coeur
en partie un amas de ruines pendant très
longtemps et tout cela a marqué
profondément est toujours là
et cédric au mouvement que ça s'est
produit aujourd'hui on est dans le
souvenir donc une forme de de résilience
mais il ya eu aussi la la le désir de
vengeance dont on reparlera puisque
c'est ce qui a motivé en fait le oscille
à l'arrêt la réponse à la réponse
américaine
la colère la colère la tristesse la
vengeance et c'est dominique
juste après
la première attaque donc de la tour nord
du world trade center est-ce que c'est
pas la convie le tournant dans les
attentats islamistes depuis 1979 que
vous décrivez dans votre dans votre de
votre nord d' extrêmement passionnante
extrêmement rigoureuse je vous cite à ce
moment là c'est la diffusion en direct
et planétaire de d'un événement
dramatique et spectaculaire et sa marque
un tournant
c'est certainement un tournant c'est à
dire que comme le rendez vous le disais
tout à l'heure au moment où les
américains triomphe aussi parce qu'il
numérise le monde et en particulier les
moyens d'information et de communication
c'est à travers cette visibilité digital
immédiate universelle qu'on assiste
aussi
à ce drame terrible et à partir de là
dans le terrorisme islamiste mondial
la scène digital va être un opérateur
extrêmement efficace de diffusion sans
la médiation des journalistes
professionnels de toutes les images
d'attentats à la manière dont les
terroristes veulent même les diffuser on
mettra beaucoup plus de temps a commencé
à réguler ça on est un peu plus
aujourd'hui mais c'est quand même encore
très très facile pour quiconque de
montrer des images sur le sur le web est
aussi d'ailleurs je le signale
d'utiliser ces mêmes d'outils pour
recruter pour la propagande et pour
recruter y compris tik tok créer plus
récemment 2016 qui est un ultime de
recueillir qui perdons je vous coupe
dominique mais si je vous suis et si je
suis cette note finalement il ya un
premier tournant 2000 à 2001 c'est le
tournant entre guillemets des chaînes
d'info en continu on peut vivre
l'événement absolu terroristes dans
celle en direct c'est ce qu'on voit la
première tour et donc percuté cnn envoie
ses hélicoptères qui sont en train de
filmer ce qui est en train de se passer
et c'est à ce moment là qu'arrive le 2
l' image que tout le monde a vu le
deuxième avion 15 heures 15h03 heure de
paris 9 heures 3 heures locales qui
percute et ça c'est l'époque chaîne
d'info en continu mais après ce que vous
dites c'est que dans les années 2010 il
y a
il y à l'algorithme et la force des
images et qui va fait mais que même les
médias traditionnels ne sont plus un
recours est un vecteur pour les
terroristes d'ailleurs c'est tous à
surfer au tournant des années 2005 2006
a pour les réseaux sociaux mais mais
même le 11 septembre est vu à travers le
web directement donc on ad on a dit il
ya des images qui sont postés par des
internautes donc on a des on s'en
souvient enfin ce qu'ils ont vécu ça à
l'époque de loin s'en souviennent aussi
jeudi deux mois j'étais à paris mais on
s'en souvient des images des photos des
photos des photos incroyables partout
dans le monde de new york où les gens
sont en train de pique nique et derrière
on voit le drame qui se déroule enfin
des photos comme ça des images de vidéos
tout ça échappe je dirais à la
régulation professionnelle des
journalistes ça déborde et c'est à la
fois ce qui marque le triomphe de la
numérisation par les américains du monde
et en même temps ce qui va donner
toute une série de clés d'entrée qui à
partir de là se voit dans la
quantification c'est le travail qu'on a
fait à la fondation pour l'innovation
politique entend quantifie le nombre
d'attentats islamistes et nombre de
victimes depuis 1979 on voit qu'à partir
de 2001 il y avait notamment une
accélération la seule cause n'est pas
des nations numériques mais on voit
qu'il ya l'accélération quantitative
c'est très impressionnant et que le
terrorisme dans sa réalité visible est
entré dans nos vies et on est tous
sortis alors bien sûr je crois que j'ai
un petit brin de zinc a complètement
raison c'est que on a le sentiment en
fait que
les faibles dans la dent dans la guerre
vous avez le faible et le fort et on
disait toujours par exemple dans la
dissuasion nucléaire vous aviez la
dissuasion du faible au fort de crâne
conservé ce qui était la doctrine
française mais là c'est vrai qu'on a
tout d'un coup à une technologie qui est
utilisé par le faible pour sortir de sa
caverne parce que auto sens je dirais
presque enfin physique du terme puisque
ben laden opère à partir d'une caverne
pendant un certain temps et tout d'un
coup il est partout il est partout donc
en fait il a gagné sur le plan sur le
plan de la reconnaissance en tout cas de
il devient médiatiquement
incontournable et ça lui donne une
puissance secte ivement comme vous dites
sur la sur le recrutement qui est qui
est vraiment très impressionnante et qui
pose un vrai problème dans cette
nouvelle gestion de la guerre du faible
au fort laurent nous dis je
qu'elle avait 9 ans mettant au moment du
11 septembre et ça se passait en direct
avec pujadas intéressant comme marque
est justement comment le cv qc vécu en
regardant la télévision pendant que
l'événement
est en train de encore de se produire
marie nous dit que l'on salue nous dit
qu'elle avait 12 ans quand elle a vu sa
également à la télévision et je salue
également tous les internautes qui nous
rejoignent actuellement sur le site du
figaro et qui nous regardent sur youtube
vous pouvez partager vos souvenirs vos
commentaires et surtout poser vos
questions à leur monde ville ancienne
correspondante à washington et ans et
grand reporter au service international
du figaro et dominique reynié directeur
général de la fondapol flat fondapol qui
publie une étude de référence sur les
attentats islamistes dans le monde
depuis 1979 jusqu'à 2009 2021 pourquoi
depuis 1979 de 1919 parce qu'il ya c'est
une année où il ya une convergence
d'événements importants la l'invasion de
l'afghanistan par l'armée rouge
la révolution on ira avec comme unis les
accords de camp david
et puis la prise d'otages
la lola prise de la mosquée à la mecque
à la mecque merci
qui montre d'ailleurs une évolution du
discours politique
du monde arabe avec une islamisation des
causes qui ne va pas ensuite cessé donc
on a en 79 une configuration qui va
pousser
cette taxe est cette phase de
développement du terrorisme islamiste
15h02 le boeing 767 correspondant au vol
175 de la compagnie united airlines
fonce alors tout droit vers la deuxième
tours du world trade center il le vol
transportant 56 passagers et neuf
membres d'équipage
percute alors la tour sud à 950 km heure
entre les 77e et 85e étage c'est l'image
du 11 septembre 2001 c'est l'image qui
sera la plus répandue qui sera image
emblématique celle que filmeront
justement les chaînes d'info continue
les chaînes d'info en continu et on voit
la tour qui commence à non seulement qui
prend feu mais qui va s'effondrer deux
heures deux heures plus tard on va
essayer de rejoindre adrien jaulmes à
washington
adrien vous êtes allé dans le mémorial
dédié aux 2700 53 morts des attentats de
new york vous le racontez dans le figaro
aujourd'hui et ce qui est notamment
intéressant c'est le contraste entre
dans ce musée la restitution de cette
journée du 11 septembre très bien faite
qui rend l'événement très présent et
puis les autres salles sur les
interventions américaines où finalement
les expéditions américaine suite aux
événements comme on en parlait tout à
l'heure avec l'or sont finalement très
peu évoquée
c'est aussi parce que le musée consacré
aux attentats du 11 septembre
particulièrement à ceux d'ailleurs même
si les salles qui parle de selon le
pentagone harry hunt à côté de
washington et de la viande le vol et
provoque presque les passagers par
s'écraser dans mon principe est bon le
but refusé cette part les center et
qu'ils puissent pas réussi parfaitement
aux pièces jaunes qui est entendu
l'appel téléphonique gentilles sdp sage
serait à prendre un temps proche des
opérateurs tirent à bon compte et les
choix des pompiers les ambulanciers
donc tout ça est très présent trail
prenant comme si on revivait
indéfiniment cette année mais c'est
aussi un dossier à mes papilles alpes il
ya une sorte de sauvetage
nos avants
curieux
et dans lequel on entend des tirs ils
ont des
victimes ce qui compte aussi des menus
premier attentat depuis 1993
le zébré
donc si cette dimension mémorielle
finalement on sait pas très bien ce que
les amériques car vous allez faire du
11-septembre du mois qui cherchent à
rappeler avec avec ce mémorial vous avez
couvert ces guerres et on retient
notamment américains livre passionnant
que vous avez écrit autour de la
campagne américaine en irak cette
histoire c'est aussi pour les américains
l'histoire d'un échec
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
l'histoire d'un échec est l'échec
particulièrement de ne pas avoir réussi
à conquérir les esprits et les coeurs
il ya indéniablement un échec les
chèques qu'elle peut être avant tout
conceptuel
l'autre chose comme si les américains
n'avaient jamais réussi à faire quoi que
ce soit vous diriez que soit cohérent de
ces attentats du 11 septembre et lors
des charges sont des attentats qui n'ont
pas un sens très facile à trouver
enfin ils sont perpétrés par
essentiellement par des saoudiens est un
pays qui n'a jamais été colonisé qui est
un pays qui a été protégé par les états
unis les états unis sont intervenus
s'arrêtera rose pour défendre le royaume
d'arabie saoudite
et puis tout à coup vous avez des
attentats qui n'ont aucune revendication
territoriale ou la part des divagations
d'appel nadal et les croisés les juges
et de citer les des terres enfin c'est
quelque chose d'assez difficile à saisir
et d'ailleurs je pense que dans ses
préparations à oublier un petit peu le
le grand désarroi
de sa brosse de la part
d'une partie en tout cas
c'est à dire lui pour arriver à
justifier ou a perpétré au genre attaque
sa tête comme
il y à un livre que vous avez préfacé
traduit que joueur commandes qui est
absolument passionnant c'est celui de
patrick cockburn le retour des
djihadistes et sa thèse est que les
américains n'ont pas pris les vraies
mesures pour combattre le djihadisme
en gros quand on le lit vous le dis si
je me trompe mais il aurait fallu que
les américains plutôt procès d'un
retournement d'alliance est alors qu'eux
ils ont gardé leur leurs alliés
traditionnels
c'est toujours difficile de dire après
coup ce qui aurait fait d'être fait ce
qu'on aurait dû faire ou deux mois de
tests c'est trop facile de le dire
est divisé la sphère qui est clair c'est
que les le grand paradoxe de toutes ces
guerres du 11 septembre c'est qu'elles
seront finalement été dirigée contre
d'autres
états du cas que celui qui était le
principal appliqué dans ses tâches et la
question je voudrais vous poser à voir
votre commentaire également dominique et
et l'or quand on lit
votre reportage donc dans le mémorial de
ground zero vous dites que ce qui est le
plus vieilli dans le mémorial ce sont
ces les discours et en particulier les
discours sur le
l'élan patriotique et l'unité l'unité
nationale
joe biden en a reparlé dans son discours
aujourd'hui
il ya une nostalgie américaine pour
cette unité qui était né dans le
traumatisme des attentats où tout le
monde était il avait un peu oublié ces
appartenances politiques les opinions
des uns et des autres et tu mens 2 se
sentait à nouveau américains munis par
une tragédie
ça n'a pas duré très longtemps puisqu'on
se souvient culte et le
deuxième mandat de georges
le président et je dépends des paraître
partait tdp dia une partie américaine
et depuis on a eu des présidences mais
on était encore plus clivante encore
contester jusqu'à la
sélection de joe biden puisqu'il n'ya
pas partie des américains et si on
auprès de sa soeur qui le décrivent
ouvertement président illégitime donc
oui il est installé en afrique est pour
le moment où ce soit à nouveau senti
hull dit où ils ont été unis autour de
quelques jours le problème c'est que
c'était une tragique
alors justement par rapport à ça et par
rapport à effectivement à cette
nostalgie qui a été exprimé par par joe
biden en outre à peut-être tout à
l'heure le message du président
américain qui a été enregistrée ces
dernières heures et vous l'écrivez le
raconter à longueur d'article
aujourd'hui l'amérique est plus divisé
que jamais
même structure allemande et viser tout à
fait c'est vrai que cette époque là
comme le dit très bien adrien c'est
aussi c'est l'époque notamment d'une
formidable vague de patriotisme et par
exemple c'était très très frappant à
l'époque qu'il y a eu des dizaines de
milliers de jeunes américains qui se
sont engagés dans l'armée et où dans les
forces du renseignement ca y est fbi y
aille police et cetera après long
septembre donc il ya eu vraiment cette
idée qu'il devait que dans ce moment de
de danger ce qu'il considérait être un
danger un péril immense pour leur pays
ils devaient ils devaient donne servir
servir leur pays d'ailleurs le mot a été
prononcé par ben hayden dans son
discours il a parlé d'unité et de
services du pays et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un moment qui
est où cette unité ce désir de service
n'est pas au premier plan en tout cas
pas chez tout le monde est au contraire
la question du patriotisme est devenue
un thème de division c'est à dire qu'au
fond
le par exemple dans la gauche dit je
dirais wow que cette gauche radicale le
patriotisme et même je dirais d'une
certaine manière de disqualifier il
s'agit au contraire de stigmatiser de
dire que là que l'amérique est un état
est un projet plein de plein de pêcher
est au fond un projet presque ce qu'ils
appellent niveau c'est à dire qui est
entachée de voix la diabolique entachée
de deux mâles alors que de ce rôle de
l'autre côté on
on se dit patriote mais c'est vrai que
il ya aussi
une une définition différente du
patriotisme donc je pense que là il ya
vraiment aujourd'hui un problème
profond et est une haine en fait une
discorde en fait qui peut qu'y qui pose
des américains les un contre un mais les
américains les uns contre les autres et
ils oublient en fait que cette cet
ennemi qu'ils ont combattu en réalité
existe toujours et je vais écouter
adrien qui disait qu'au fond
l'un des problèmes pour les etats unis
c'est le désarroi à à définir pourquoi
il se bat pour quoi ils se sont battus
et qu'est ce que vous voulez vraiment
les auteurs du 11 septembre et c'est
vrai que mes mais c'est vrai que c'est
difficile parce qu'effectivement ce
n'est pas une attaque a été perpétrée
par un état dont xipaya pas de
déclaration de guerre d'un état contre
l'amérique au rendu en septembre ces
messieurs c'est clairement une
déclaration de guerre d'une idéologie
islamiste pour laquelle l'occident c'est
l'ennemi mais en fait il ya une haine de
l'occident derrière derrière faudra voir
revenir sur ce moment là mais j'aurais
dominique justement puisque à la
fondapol vous avez également publié une
note très substantiel sur l'idéologie
hook de notre ancien confrère du figaro
pierre valentin
quel est votre frère il a 24 ans donc
c'est àdire son
talent mais
j'espère le
il n'y est plus
le la question justement que je vous
posais autour de ça c'est que est ce que
vous êtes quel est votre regard
justement sur cette société américaine
et sur cette division de sociétés
américaines est ce que finalement l'élan
patriotique que et d'unité nationale
qu'on observe au lendemain du 11
septembre et est un souvenir qui est
rendu
enfin qu'il est impossible impossible de
revivre ce genre d'événement à cause des
divisions structurelles
keane que l'on a vu
se manifester depuis deux ans environ
aux états unis avec le mouvement black
light matters les déboulonnage de statut
et l'idéologie look dans les universités
eh mec à moi je suis pas un spécialiste
états unis j'ai pas de compétences
particulières je remarquerai simplement
qu'il ya une crise non pas pour en
parler je vous rassure vincent roux mais
il ya une crise du monde démocratique et
les états unis sont fragilisés 1 je
dirais en été aux avant postes de ce
monde démocratique il ya sans doute une
crise américaine je lis ce qui se dit
par les personnes compétentes et laure
mandeville en particulier il connaît
parfaitement le pays il ya une crise de
ce type après j'ai une petite réserve
sur un point non pas sur l'évaluation de
la crise la division très profonde et ça
a permis de terminer rapidement en
accrochant la question du moc isme il ya
un élément qui
quand même fait que les états unis
restent number one c'est
l'innovation la recherche là encore
récemment sur
penalty sur la fusion nucléaire est là
une innovation extraordinaire annoncé je
suis pas capable de dire
enfin de la mighty c'est quand même
sérieux une grande innovation annoncé ce
que font les entrepreneurs américains
dans la conquête de l'espace est
prodigieux donc il ya cette puissance là
cette puissance de l'esprit qui est
totale qui est le fruit des fruits de la
liberté c'est on n'a pas de science si
on n'a pas la liberté après c'est là la
question niveau qu'ils aiment c'est in
libéralisme de gauche est en mesure
de porter un poison
d'intolérance de violence stigmatisation
et même une pensée totalitaire au coeur
des universités américaines et au fond
d'eux d'enrayer l'extraordinaire
capacité de ce pays à produire des
élites remarquable et des élites qui
sont américaines ou qui sont venus du
monde entier pour la ja danger très
particulier parce que si les américains
étaient attaqués sur cette capacité à
produire une élite pour eux mêmes et à
contribuer dans le monde à la
fabrication des zénith là nous aurions
une difficulté universel et en
particulier pour les états unis et le
monde démocratique
une autre une autre question par rapport
à ce que soulever adrien justement ya
derrière disais et lors il revenait à
l'instant d'habitude quand il ya des
attentats finalement il y avait un
certain nombre de buts de but précis les
attentats qu'on a connue en france même
partir des années 80 il y avait un
certain nombre de buts il faut les payer
des dettes à l'iran et arrêter de
soutenir le gouvernement algérien dans
les années 90 les attentats du gia et
c'est là qu'elle est le finalement le
but de ces attentats islamistes qui se
répondent comme vous le soulignez dans
votre note partout dans le partout dans
le monde est-ce que c'est qu'on libère
jérusalem comme le dit
comme le dit ben laden inciter tout à
l'heure par
il ya une revendication qui fait qu'on
peut
utiliser cette catégorie des attentats
islamistes bergère hellemmes entre
guillemets bien en tant que je suis bien
sûr
faisait référence à cette revendication
dans le sillage de cette évolution de la
drague la cause mais il y a une il y à
une islamisation de la cause terroriste
et etc c'est l'islam politique c'est à
dire c'est l'idée alors très vague et un
peu absurde c'est l'idée qu'il est temps
maintenant de destituer le monde
occidental la culture occidentale
accablé de tous toutes les fautes tous
les péchés et d'instaurer un ordre
islamistes universel faisant cesser les
césar c'est dans l'idée même de
l'islamisme c'est que le la consécration
se fait dans un gouvernement universel
islamistes donc ccc ccc ce projet là qui
va associer sont la bienvenue à partir
de 119 et en afghanistan qui va associer
des dizaines de milliers de musulmans
islamistes à travers le monde et qui
vont venir y compris de l'europe comme
on le sait beaucoup d' algérie dira
qu'ils vont aller en afghanistan
combattre l'armée rouge et puis qui vont
ensuite à force de guerroyer à acquérir
une compétence et des capacités qui vont
les amener un peu partout dans le monde
alors quand je dis partout c'est plutôt
l'afrique du nord l'afrique
subsaharienne l'asie du sud le prochain
ils n'ont rien bien sûr et là c'est une
c'est toute une guérilla qui se met en
place avec le lac mais qu'est la
création de l'état islamique même s'il
ne dure pas longtemps c'est un point je
dirais qu'ils éclairent la manière
dénoncé la cause
un autre une autre question peut-être
adrien
qui est avec nous encore chinatown
puisqu'on n'avait pas je tends entendu
bien la réponse tout à l'heure là encore
on a les images en ce moment donc à new
york en direct on a revu joe biden au
milieu d'ailleurs de d'autres d'autres
personnalités de noyer un petit peu avec
avec un masque est ce que les américains
aujourd'hui redoutent encore parmi les
les peurs fondamentale un attentat
islamiste où effectivement est-ce que
leurs préoccupations d'abord c'est
plutôt sortir de là de la pandémie
si on se rappelle les les attentats du
11 septembre à new york et même les mois
qui avaient suivi observez eu
d'attentât y avait eu cette campagne de
terrain à des lettres foisonner avec de
leurs actes a été envoyée mais si on se
rappelle tout ça le contraste est assez
frappant avec le diop de 2020 2021
civile parce que avant frappé par an des
corps un virus qui est payant et on est
venu pour que des kits amérique
d'accrocher une mort quasi espèces il ya
eu énormément de victimes
ça a été un vrai tôt m donc oui journal
un peu la pression le recteur actuel la
crise est là qu auront payé à
cette réponse à des
prisons plus diffuse
merci beaucoup adrien et merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous en direct pour
justement nous faire nous éclairer sur
l'état d'esprit côté américain est sûre
la façon dont les états unis commémorent
vingt ans après
7,7 anniversaire donc des attentats du
11-septembre voyez en direct les images
à new york je revis je signale
d'ailleurs donc votre vos reportages et
votre décryptage votre récit des 20 ans
en qui nous sépare donc entre ces
attentats est aujourd'hui est également
votre reportage donc au mémorial à
ground zero qui se trouve dans le chat
est bien sûr on n'oublie pas à merak est
également le livre de patrick cockburn
que vous avez traduit et préfacé le
retour des djihadistes c'est aux
éditions des équateurs
dominique je reviens vers vous
justement il ya il ya quelque chose qui
est frappant dans les commentaires que
l'on voit en tous les cas d'un certain
nombre d'analystes et de peut-être de
stratège il y a cette idée qui en tous
les cas cette cette critique contre les
états unis
qui est d'avoir voulu imposer par la
force deux notions qui vous sont chers
qui sont la démocratie et la
civilisation
oui oui c'est oui c'est un
c'est un modèle qui qui qui part quand
même d'un
d'un pari très risqué 1 c'est l'idée
qu'on peut fabriquer des démocraties
c'est l'idée que l'on peut
même en utilisant la force
transformé rapidement un pays
un peuple
un régime démocratique e
c'est une des grandes idées des
etats-unis de leur diplomatie et puis de
leur utilisation de l'appareil militaire
aussi
d'une certaine manière ça n'a pas
toujours été un échec mais mais enfin la
l'espèce ça n'a pas fonctionné et c'est
parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui peut
être peut-être que c'est plus difficile
pour les american de comprendre parce
que c'est une nation très jeune ça on le
sait même si on mesure pas à quel point
c'est important comme différence et les
amériques en gamme le sentiment qu'on a
pu en deux siècles fabriquer la plus
grande démocratie du monde et de
l'histoire mais partout ailleurs parce
que c'était des européens en fait qui
avait une histoire et longitudinales
très profonde mais partout ailleurs il a
fallu une culture démocratique et les
institutions ne font pas une démocratie
des institutions sont importantes quand
il y a une culture démocratique quand il
y a une population un peuple qui qui a
absorbé les principes fondamentaux qui
les partagent qui voit bien ce que ans
quel point il y de la complice la nature
humaine dans la liberté et la légal
dignité des individus mais mais si vous
êtes dans un univers qui culturellement
had mais l'inégalité radical il ya des
passages entre les hommes et les femmes
qui admet manière définitive que la
religion la religion est au dessus et au
dessous de tout et de la loire et il a
le fin mot de la politique et qu'au fond
il faut un régime théologico politique
et qu'il n'y a pas de séparation
acceptable que la liberté d'opinion ne
peut pas exister que l'individu n'a pas
n'a pas de liberté qui doit tout à la
communauté avec ça vous ferait pas une
démocratie donc il faudra beaucoup de
temps et au fond les etats-unis en ont
peut-être vos produits ce qui leur est
arrivé au reste du monde en oubliant
qu'ils étaient les héritiers en fait des
européens et que les européens ont mis
beaucoup de temps à découvrir tout cela
le comprendrez que ça n'a pas été une
partie facile non oui je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce que dit
dominique reynié et c'est vrai que quand
vous regardez la démocratie américaine
on
ce tendance à oublier que la démocratie
américaine se construit sur le substrat
de la culture politique britannique et
avec des ajouts bien sûr c'est mon
excuse mais c'est vrai que comme le
disait tocqueville la démocratie c'est
un fait social avant d'être un fait
politique et ça ça ramène c'est pourquoi
on à se défendre des enchantements
aujourd'hui c'est parce que les états
unis ont fait en fait un certain nombre
d'erreurs majeures la première erreur et
là je suis d'accord avec vous
le lait
comment dire aux auditeurs en fait qui
vous interpeller c'est que effectivement
quand les américains lancent leur
opération en afghanistan c'est une ils
veulent aller chercher ben laden et
al-qaïda et essayer de détruire cette
organisation pour les punir de ce qu'ils
ont fait donc ça c'est la première chose
est de 7 de ce point de vue là on peut
dire que leur opération est légitime
parce que c'est représenter une menace
il venait de de perpétrer un attentat
absolument monstrueux contre eux mais le
problème c'est que ya ce que les
américains appellent le méchant quick
c'est à dire il ya un changement de
mission pande vers décembre 2000 après
avoir mis en déroute en fait al qaïda et
même les talibans les héberger qui
hébergeait al qaïda les américains ne se
résolvent pas à vous n'arrive pas à
attraper ben laden qui a réussi à
s'enfuir parce que là la fameuse
frontière n'est pas assez mais il part
vers le pakistan et est donc à ce moment
là il ya toujours cette colère qui
habitent les états unis il y à un
certain nombre de deux équipes néo
conservatrice qui se trouve alors au
pouvoir au tour de george w bush et qui
lui conseille de détourner la le 11
septembre finalement et de porter le fer
contre l'irak et c'est là l'erreur
absolument majeur qui est fait par
l'équipe de bush et il est donné aux
conservateurs en 2000 en 2003 puisqu'il
s'en vont en irak où ils vont sembler
très dans un véritable désastre
qui a débouché sur finalement ce que
l'on voit aujourd'hui c'est à dire
retrait de l' influence américaine au
moyen orient et alors pour pour terminer
donc c'est vrai qu'ils ont été épaulés
les néoconservateurs qui pensaient
qu'ils pouvaient construire des nations
porter la démocratie à la force des
baïonnettes ont été soutenus par les
néolibéraux qui à gauche eux aussi
étaient aux en faveur d'un l'exportation
la démocratie pas nécessairement par la
force juste le libéralisme états unis
c'est la gauche c'était la gauche est en
réalité qui était le camp démocrate et
donc vous avez une alliance en france on
fait nos dix de ces deux de ces deux
camps pour faire de la politique
américaine politique profondément
interventionniste et militarisé mais
c'est vrai que ça n'avait pas toujours
été le cas et que dans le passé les
américains se sont parfois compte
intenter de dison défendre les valeurs
démocratiques mais mais pas du volant
les imposer par la force et par exemple
l'époque même de la guerre froide n'est
pas une époque où on essaie de changer
l'urss où le camp
est européens de l'intérieur on ya le
conteneur qui est une doctrine
d'endiguement qui avait été mis en place
par george kennan et mais pas du tout
une doctrine le néo conservatrice et
d'ailleurs george clinton avant de
mourir avait exprimé son désaccord avec
le néo conservatisme et c'est estimant
que l'amérique n'avait pas à les changer
les régimes et que la démocratie ne
pouvait venir que de l'intérieur on veut
on va y revenir tout à peut-être tout à
l'heure en commentant les justement les
images en pennsylvanie sont alors une
scène un peu étonnante au niveau des
personnalités jeu j'ai besoin d'avoir
votre réaction à ce moment là mais avant
que dominique reynié nous nous quitte
j'ai deux petites questions que vous
vous posez dominique relativement à
l'étude que vous avez
réalisée qui fait référence donc sur les
attentats islamistes de 1979 à 2021 il
ya un autre phénomène dans ces années là
c'est la situation de la france dans les
années 2000 finalement
on observe ce qui se passe en termes
d'attentats islamistes
ailleurs dans le monde mais la france
n'est pas n'est pas touché et alors
qu'aujourd'hui la france est devenue une
cible prioritaire des islamistes et des
islamistes violents absolument alors la
france a été victime d'attentats de ce
type de manière marginale un peu avant
mais effectivement ça n'arrive à 80
voire 90 81 98 après sa semaine à
d'autres choses enfin c'est mais il est
certain que à partir de 2 des actions de
mohamed merah donc mars 2012 il y à un
changement pardon je vous coupe pourquoi
la france ne
jouit mais pourquoi la france n'a pas
été touché par les par al qaïda dans les
années 2000 oui bon c'est une question
difficile à vincent au jeu puisque ce
qui me vient à l'esprit en tout cas
c'est
si je m'inscris dans le droit fil est ce
que disait normandie valeurs vous
rappelle que la france
sur l'opération en irak a pris une
position extraordinairement
forte et très différentes
alors que les espagnols les italiens
et les britanniques se sont engagés
enfin en tout cas via leurs
représentants dans ce conflit auprès des
américains aux pays qui ont été
lourdement touchée par les attentats
islamistes de ces années là les
attentats de madrid les attentats de
londres
et puis les italiens à naciria on ira
voilà et et madrid c'est un de ceux de
2004 et ses 240 m'enfin c'est un
désastre londres 2005 demande mais trop
s'en souvient bref et neuf morts et là
il ya ya ya ya une espèce de bascule qui
se fait au détriment de la france après
après 2012 avec mohamed bien en tout cas
et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui la france est
le pays le plus touché où ça de l'union
européenne
il ya depuis
80 deux attentats islamistes 800
332 morts pardon aujourd'hui mais
surtout 88 % de ces attentats
de ces morts pardon eu lieu depuis 2013
et deux tiers de ces attentats ont eu
lieu depuis 2013 c'est à dire que début
2013 on est vraiment dans un mouvement
de pousser de la violence terroriste
islamiste en france et d'ailleurs si
vous me permettrez il ajouté vincent
roux à partir de cette étude et qui dit
ce qui est disponible gratuitement sur
le site de la fondation parce que
fondapol point mort parce qu'on peut il
ya des tableaux des données on a quand
même a répertorié plus de 48 l'attentât
et on a pu je dirais validé deux cent
dix mille victimes
en réalité c'est beaucoup plus mais on
n'a pas le temps d'en discuter parce
qu'on a des problèmes de de
sous-estimation qui sont indépassables
mais surtout sur le plan général global
et 1919 ce qui me frappe quand je vois
les données qu'on a pu extraire on a
fait une base de données qui permet de
faire des calculs c'est qu'en réalité
nous sommes depuis 2013 dans la poussée
du terrorisme islamiste c'est à dire que
la phase là - la moins active si je puis
dire c'est 1979 2000 il ya des attentats
il y en à 2194 et 6817 victimes à partir
de 2011 2012 il ya eu un développement
multiplie par quatre tous ces chiffres
mais 2013
2021 c'est une véritable explosion et si
je si je veux y affine encore le regard
la poussée est encore plus nette entre
2019 et mai 2021 jeudi mais pas sur cet
arrêté en mai pour pouvoir livrer le
document il fallait s'arrêter un peu
avant on est en réalité que là les
auditeurs le comprenne bien on parle
d'un événement qui a lieu il ya 20 ans
la page est tournée peut-être pour le 11
septembre et pour le terrorisme
islamiste il n'a jamais été aussi
virulents il est beaucoup plus depuis
2013 et il est intensément depuis 2019
ce qui ne me paraît pas être présent
dans les commentaires que nous faisons
sur le 11 septembre et grâce à vous il
est l'or c'est votre point de vue aussi
mis enfin tout à fait chaud tout ça est
tout à fait juste je me demande en fait
si justement le fait que la france ne
soit plus touché après 2010 en fait
après enfin dans la deuxième période là
et c'est nice qui commence en 2010 c'est
pas parce que
d'abord les états unis sont
mené un travail de deux intérieurs de
surveillance de
démantèlement de 2000 qui rend peut-être
plus difficile même s'il ya eu quelques
uns commission de 30 ans aux états unis
et donc aux attentes à 2 quand même
digard nice je te dis oui il ya eu il ya
eu un horaire nardine etc mais c'est
vrai que je pense que la france va à
parer aux mouvements et aux mouvements
islamistes qui cherchent à frapper les
esprits puisque on l'a dit il s'agit de
frapper les esprits de frappe de pour
que pour faire peur pour semer le doute
pour semer la discorde et ils se rendent
compte à ce moment là qu'il ya un pays
idéal pour ça d'abord parce que si on
frappe si on casse la france ont
finalement l'europe d'une certaine
manière je dirais pas qu'elle s'effondre
mais en termes de résistance à eau à la
question de l'islamisme la france est
quand même en une tête de proue parce
qu'à cause de la laïcité à cause du fait
que malgré tout historiquement c'est la
fille aînée de l'église
il ya il ya un faisceau d'éléments
portée symbolique serait forte
symbolique absolument énorme puissante
sur la france et donc et il ya en plus
un écosystème puisque la france est un
pays où il ya une communauté musulmane
on peut aller chercher des fous de dieu
les formes et les recruter parce que
justement il ya une grande communauté
musulmane donc il ya une capacité à
essayer de de les endoctriner et je
pense que cette rencontre entre
l'écosystème français et la porter la
charge symbolique de la france explique
peut-être pourquoi on a été tellement
touché ces dernières années c'est parce
que vous en pensez je crois que ça fait
partie des éléments qui expliquent cela
l'engagement de la france aussi en
afghanistan depuis le mali la la la la
prétention je lui dis de manière
non pas négative
la conviction que la france d'avoir à
protéger les siens sur des territoires
extérieurs en luttant contre l'islamisme
est aussi une des causes
puis il y à 7,7 me dirige cette
expression de la liberté d'opinion en
france
ce rapport critique aux religions y
compris dans le dans l'expression delà
de la moquerie qui a fait de la france
une soeur fait de la luge en a justement
charlie hebdo oui ça avait commencé avec
salman rushdie dans la littérature au
royaume uni en 1988 ces versets
sataniques first and il n'a pas été ça
n'a pas ça ne s'est pas arrêtée là mais
la france avec charlie hebdo et cette
liberté qui est tu as un héritage de la
tradition française de la liberté de
l'esprit critique lui coûte lui coûte
effectivement 7 me les attentats contre
charlie hebdo qui ont eu lieu en 2015
interviennent après ceux de ceux de
méras leur tour cessé meira et dont le
premier la première attaque est
contraint justement coreligionnaires
musulmans des hoquets liddy qui est
militaire français à montauban et évoqua
lydie tutu mais nos frères en
afghanistan je te tue donc il ya quelque
chose qu'il semble clé également au
conflit en afghanistan juste un mot on
voit les images donc 2
la commémoration en ce moment à
arlington aux etats unis c'est l'hommage
aux victimes du boeing 757 de la
compagnie american airlines 65 morts qui
s'était écrasé contre la façade ouest du
pentagone près de washington
le bâtiment abrite le département de la
défense je vais juste un commentaire de
votre part parce que vous êtes intéressé
sur ces questions à l'association la
dominique c'est aussi l'attaqué contre
le pentagone un tournant puisque chez
nous ça va donner lieu à un regain est
un phénomène qui apprendre énormément
d'ampleur c'est le conspirationnisme
avec en particulier une figure de la
gauche progressiste et anti sioniste en
france thierry meyssan fondateur du
réseau voltaire
qui jusque là est spécialisée dans la
lutte contre le catholicisme et ce qu'il
appelle l'ordre moral et qui va faire un
livre qui a un retentissement mondial et
qui est la bible du conspirationnisme
c'est vrai vous avez raison ce projet
est absolument fascinant puisqu'il ya
même des thèses négationnistes sur un
surnombre en septembre bien est-ce qu'on
peut conspirationnistes sur ses
organisateurs là aussi on retrouve un
lien entre le terrorisme ce terrorisme
là en tout cas et ça s'appliquera
d'autres événements et la numérisation
du monde de la digitalisation qui va
énerver en quelque sorte servir de
matrice à
la multiplication de deux thèses
farfelues à la diffusion des thèses et
les foutaises autour du 11 septembre ces
gens guînes et défèquent news aussi
enfin les rampes dans ce monde où la
vérité est extrêmement difficile à
trouver et quand on est avertis parce
que c'est le métier de faire attention
on n'est pas à l'abri
de ce piège là imaginant pour tous nos
concitoyens qui n'ont pas forcément le
temps de vérifier beaucoup de choses
nous sommes rentrés dans un âge
compliqué il y compris pour identifier
la vérité des attentats islamistes dans
le monde depuis 1979 jusqu'à 2021 c'est
une étude inédite et de référence qui a
été réalisé par la fondapol dirigée par
dominique reynié merci d'être passé par
les studios du figaro pour pouvoir
commenter d'abord ces images et cet
événement et pour pouvoir
nous en parler il faut là que vous
reveniez pour qu on vous en reparle
ensemble merci beaucoup dominique laure
je me retourne vers vous on a ouvert le
procès des attentats de paris cette
semaine
six ans après les faits mais il n'y a
toujours pas eu de procès pour le 11
septembre c'est vrai en fait il ya ce
procès doit se tenir il doit d'ailleurs
il ya il doit y avoir regardé il ya eu
un certain nombre de hearing déjà qui
ont été tenus mais ça se passe dans un
cadre le cadre d'un d'un tribunal
militaire si je ne me trompe pas et
mais ce procès n'a toujours pas eu
effectivement est en cours commencé et
on attend toujours que au niveau des
audiences préliminaires est ce qu il y a
encore aujourd'hui des zones dont sur le
11 septembre sur l' enquête sur le 11
septembre alors il ya il ya eu notamment
en faire je me souviens mois au moins du
dixième anniversaire des interrogations
sur le lien entre
les saoudiens et l'on septembre quelque
chose qui a été entretenue il ya eu un
certain nombre de deux personnes qui ont
évoqué en fait l'idée que la l'ambassade
d'arabie saoudite avait été au courant
puis après finalement ça a été démenti
ça reste un peu nébuleux toutes ces
affaires
donc est ce qu'il reste des notes donc
je crois que
adrien souligné que la zone dont c'était
au fond pourquoi il attaque
on a parlé du fait que c'est l attaque
contre l'occident mais sinon
en fait le
je pense qu'il ya eu vous savez une
commission en fête post 11 septembre qui
qui a énormément travaillé rendu des
des conclusions etc mais certains
passages on avait été et ont été
interdits de publication des noms n'ont
pas été rendus publics
je crois que c'est toujours le cas en
fait qu'il ya encore quelques extraits
depuis qu'ils ont très justement à aux
liens entre les saoudiens et l'arabie
saoudite cetera
voilà c'est ce que je peux en dire pour
l'instant les emprisonnement à
guantanamo les interrogatoires il ya eu
des interrogatoires avec torture à 143
simulation de noyade pour abou mohammed
le cerveau présumé des attentats est ce
que ça a donné quelque chose finalement
pour ces enquêtes est ce que ça a donné
est-ce que ça a contribué
est-ce que alors est-ce que ça suive
cité normande peut les mener normalement
est ce que ça a apporté quelque chose
renseignements mais je suis pas sûr en
fait en tout cas il ya plusieurs agents
de la cia ye dont l'un avait une femme
en fait donc à partir de laquelle il ya
eu un film dont elle a été inspirée ce
fameux film avec cette actrice vous avez
chastain il ya eu tous que je puis
comment s'appelle ce film j'ai oublié le
nom est en fait l'équipe ce film en fait
il fait à partir de témoignages
notamment d'agents de la cia y et qui
disent que la torture ce n'est pas la
torture qui a permis d'obtenir des
informations
donc que sap a été absolument décisif
pour obtenir des informations sur ce qui
s'était passé au moment du 11 septembre
et pour retrouver les les feux les
fauteurs et c'est donc bien sûr
qu'aujourd'hui il ya toujours cette ce
débat énorme en fait sur sûr on n'aurait
jamais dû faire ça on a sali notre
démocratie et vous avez le débat qui
revient aujourd'hui sur la fermeture de
guantanamo mais il ya toujours 40 go
into ne vous est pas conviée par ferry
toujours pas fait sens avait été promis
par barack obama tu as fait et il a pas
pu le faire parce que il ya eu d'abord
une un blocage par le congrès notamment
par les républicains au congrès parce
que la question qui se pose est celle où
on met les prisonniers dans un hameau
qui échappe et au droit américain dans
la manière dont ils ont été justement
interrogé
appréhendé souvent dans des écrans que
des circonstances totalement
contraire en fait au droit
international ou les amériques les des
équipes américaines sont allés les
chercher dans d'autres territoires ils
ont été torturés et c est donc les
mettre dans des prisons américaines
c'était d'un point de vue légal ça
posait d'énormes problèmes et donc ils
ont retourné cette affaire dans tous les
sens et la seule solution qu'ils ont
trouvée ces deux peu à peu faire
diminuer le nombre de prisonniers en
espérant qu'un jour on allait finir par
envoyée il ya eu donc un ambassadeur qui
a été en charge de rendre de faire
renvoyer en négociant des accords avec
différents pays pour qu'ils aillent
purgé leur peine ailleurs etc etc il je
crois qu'il reste actuellement 49
détenus à guantanamo donc est-ce que
byden pourra fermer guantanamo alors
qu'ils le souhaitent je ne pense pas que
ce soit l'une de ses premières priorités
on va écouter précisément joe biden qui
a fait une déclaration ces dernières
heures juste avant donc ces
commémorations on a vu tout à l'heure le
président américain à new york avec son
prédécesseur
barack obama dont il avait été le
vice-président des et
le président donc américain qui est
exprimé sa nostalgie à l'égard du
gard du 11 septembre on écoute
une seule
équipe est
unie ben oui le
dynamisme des breaks you never mind the
gap est tombée enceinte au
moment
où
les
états
respectent ni
ni
besson
joe biden donc message adressé à
l'amérique quelques heures avant le
début des commémorations que nous vous
faisons vivre en direct sur le site du
figaro avec un live qui vous fait
revivre cette journée du 11 septembre
minute par minute également un live sur
les commémorations en cours aux états
unis et bien sûr cela une vidéo avec
lequel avec qui nous avons où nous avons
le plaisir d'avoir laure mandeville
grand reporter au service international
ancienne correspondante à washington
pour commenter justement ces images on
le voit à l'instant les images de la
cérémonie à arlington on commémore donc
le crash sur le pentagone à 9h45 à
l'époque en pennsylvanie
15h45 sur figaro live dans un quart
d'heure justement chaque ville on va se
recueillir en mémoire des passagers du
crash à plus de 900 kilomètres heure du
vol de 93 de united airlines suite à une
révolte des 44 passagers
laure mandeville est ce qu on sait
justement aujourd'hui qu'elle était la
cible des terroristes qui
piloter l'avion qui s'est écrasé en
pennsylvanie
on est quasiment persuadés que la cible
était la maison blanche où le capitole
et c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu cette
panique extrême
effectivement quand cet avion a été
détecté et que les états unis ont décidé
d'envoyer des chasseurs pour abattre
l'avion pour empêcher qu'il y ait plus
de morts si jamais cet avion se
transformer en véritable bombe vivante
sur une des principales institutions
américaines on avait même demandé à une
je crois que le détail dit que c'était
une femme pilote qui était un des
chasseurs qui s'est élevée dans l'air à
ce moment là mais il n'avait pas eu le
temps de charger leurs avions tellement
ils sont partis vite et donc il avait
demandé à cette vie lot de se
transformer en avions suicides pour
aller détourner cet avion finalement ça
n'a pas été nécessaire puisqu'on sait
qu'il ya eu 7 cette espèce de rébellion
des passagers qui dans un acte de
bravoure
extrêmes se sont précipités vers le
cockpit où se trouvaient les terroristes
pour essayer de les assaillir et donc
cela a provoqué finalement le le
l'écrasement de l'avion le crash donc à
chaque ville à shanksville donc juste à
côté de pittsburgh en pennsylvanie
sur place on va les voir dans instant
sans doute se rendent l'ancien président
george bush
et l'actuelle vice-présidente camélat
harris il n'y a rien de commun entre les
deux heures entre george bush oui
absolument il n'y a rien de commun et
c'est vrai que ils sont là réunis par
l'importance de cet événement et ce qui
est vrai ce qui frappe aussi c'est que
donald trump n'est pas là
donald ramenait pas là est ce qu'on sait
pourquoi et alors justement
il n'est pas là parce qu est ce qu il a
été invité je ne sais pas s'il a été
invitée déjà et ça va faire montre on en
revient à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
c'est à dire ça montre que dans ce
moment dans de joe biden dit qu'il doit
être un moment de total unités
parce que l'unité c'est la plus grande
force du peuple américain
finalement il ya un vide béant à la
place où ils devraient se tenir
et
ce qui est intéressant je trouve que
chez dyson donc il a parlé d' empathie
dans ce discours évidemment parce que
c'est un homme de l'empathie qu'il a
tenus là connu de tels drames dans sa
vie que pour tout cela évidemment tous
les drames de ces familles qui ont été
séparés par le 11 septembre
les pères qui ont perdu leurs enfants
les enfants qui ont perdu leur père les
femmes qui ont perdu leurs maris et vice
versa il a vécu lui à travers sa vie
puisqu'il a connu des drames terribles
avec la mort dans un accident de sa
femme et de sa fille puis la perte de
son fils qui était promis à un brillant
avenir et qui s'étaient battus d'aller
en irak et donc tout cela c'est vrai que
on ressent l'émotion de joe biden et je
crois qu ils communient en
émotionnellement avec le pays c'est vrai
que aussi ce qui est intéressant c'est
que byden il a vécu un peu de tout les
toutes les étapes de la du changement en
fait de da proche des etats-unis
vis-à-vis de du 11-septembre de
l'afghanistan etc parce que dans un
premier temps quand le 11 septembre se
produit il est absolument horrifié il se
précipite au congrès il ne peut pas
rentrer ce jour là il est sur un banc à
six appelant george bush immédiatement
il arrive à lui parlé de trois minutes
pour le lui dire mais il faut agir je
vais rentrer à washington
on va continuer
de revivre cette année cette anecdote
avec vous je vous propose de vivre de
partager justement l'instant qui
s'est dit là où on les voit justement
ensemble en voix de george bush est ce
que je vous disais c'est que le revois
kamala harris aussi oui exactement et
son mari et
donc ce fameux jour du 11 septembre joe
biden a appelé georges de beauce une
touche en lui disant il faut vous
rentriez à washington ont ils pour
redonner un sens de normes forme de
normalité à ce qui se passe parce que
c'est vrai que tout le monde était c'est
elle et moi le plus total on savait pas
s'il a la maison blanche allait être
attaqué il fallait mettre le président à
l'abri etc il y avait une
totale sentiment que le pays était
attaqué de toutes parts et était en
grand danger et c'est vrai que joe biden
du coup va va en fait ensuite
voter pour soutenir en fait et soutenir
la le départ des troupes américaines en
afghanistan pour venger ce qui s'est
passé est allé trouver ben laden ben
laden il va aussi voter l'intervention
en irak mais ensuite c'est vrai qu'il va
être un des premiers à le freiner cette
intervention afghane ce qui explique sa
voix la position qu'il a prises
aujourd'hui pour un retrait
sens sans vouloir laisser de troupes
deux points dissuasif il ne voulait pas
en entendre parler parce que très vite
en fait déjà à partir de 2008 où il se
rend là-bas à la voir le président
karzaï il va se rendre compte que 7 on
est en train de conduire et président
afghan qui va lui arrive qu'ils étaient
installés au pouvoir steiner pouvoir par
la coalition qui a renversé les taliban
directement et donc il s'aperçoit que
derrière cette espèce d'espoir de
construire une nation démocratique
afghanes ont il va se heurter à toutes
ces
tribus la corruption
le népotisme généralisé le fait que
toute l'aide américaine où disparaît il
comprend en fait que les américains sont
dans un piège et il va passer son temps
dans les mois qui suivent à dire à obama
que il faut se retirer alors qu'obama
relance sous la pression des généraux
américains en 2009 à son arrivée un peu
à contrecoeur parce que lui aussi son
instinct était partir relance là ce
qu'on a appelé le ce nouveau sorges
c'est à dire une un renforcement des
troupes
baydan ces deux là où il est on a eu la
conquête de l'esprit et du coeur en
afghanistan ça à la radio contre
insurrection et contre-insurrection qui
avait été initié en irak avec les
attributs exactement on voit justement
se recueillir donc
le l'ancien président américain george w
bush et de l'autre côté kamala harris
alors que justement on voit
de nouveau discours
prononcé avant une minute de silence
normalement qui doit être observée aux
alentours de 16 heures 03 ici à
shanksville
à propos de camélat harris
notre consoeur isabelle lasserre
aujourd'hui site le conseiller à la
sécurité de la vice-présidente
américaine qui était de passage à paris
et je voulais partager cette cette
déclaration qu'il a faite avec vous il
dit à chaque fois que les américains ont
décidé de changer des régimes ils ont
surestimé la menace mais sous-estimé les
coûts et les risques on déclare toujours
prématurément victoire corps au début ça
marche il est facile de faire tomber un
pouvoir quand on est la première
puissance militaire du monde mais ça
finit toujours mal et il ne reste plus
que des fausses promesses les gens
n'aiment pas qu'on décide à leur place
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
clairement une critique des
néoconservateurs qui était notamment
très présent au tour de georges tout à
fait comme on le disait tout à l'heure
c'est exactement ça c'est que je crois
que dans l'équipe de joe biden il y a
clairement l'idée aujourd'hui que le néo
conservatisme et les guerres les
interventions militaires
pour aller à la force des baïonnettes
installer des régimes démocratiques
s'est terminée que l'amérique doit se
concentrer sur son sur ses problèmes
intérieurs qui sont immenses et je crois
que c'est tout à fait présent chez by
dance mais c'est aussi une critique
quand je disais des néolibéraux c'est à
dire des faucons
de la gauche également et on appelait 0
contre la gauche est ce qu'il ya des
faucons de la gauche oui alors j'aurai
le gland dans son équipe c'était le clan
de hillary clinton en fait plus tôt
et
il y a des gens au sein de l'équipe
de joe biden qui sont beaucoup plus
allants pour sur la question de la
défense des valeurs démocratiques à
l'étranger pas nécessairement par la
force mais par exemple quelqu'un comme
victorian hollande qui est le numéro
trois du département d'état
était plus je dirais sur la ligne
clinton
mais c'est vrai que clairement
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt la ligne des
réalistes qui était la ligne d'obama en
fait aussi qui est
n'avons rien à faire sur tous ces
terrains
moyen-orientaux nous sommes incapables
de changer les choses positivement nous
devons être plus humble et c'est il faut
bien voir ton qui les ont choisis de la
boutique absolument et là on est dans la
continuité de donald trump qui a été
je dirais le premier à
plaider pour
avec obama mais obama finalement n'a pas
fait ce qu'il avait plaidé en tout cas
pas totalement puisqu'il est intervenue
en libye
en revanche il n'a pas voulu intervenir
en syrie précisément à cause de ces
précisément sur ces thèmes là parce
qu'il était convaincu que c'était pas
possible
et vous avez trump ensuite qui a repris
très fortement cette idée des guerres
comment dire sans faim auxquelles il
fallait mettre fin et du réalisme en
politique que
étrangères nos intérêts nationaux
l'amérique d'abord ça veut dire se
concentrer sur nos propres problèmes ça
ne veut pas dire parfois férus de ne pas
faire usage de la force dans son optique
mais n'en faire qu'un usage extrêmement
parcimonieuse
il ya une autre citation je vais
partager avec vous c'est samuel
huntington cécité par un internaute du
figaro et qui situation un petit peu
longue mais que je vous partage quand
même ligne petit culturaliste américain
rejette l'héritage culturel de leur pays
il souhaite créer un pays aux
civilisations multiples c'est à dire un
pays n'appartenant à aucune civilisation
est dépourvu d'unité culturelle
l'histoire nous apprend qu'aucun état
ainsi constitué n'a jamais perdurer en
tant que société c'est intéressant quand
vous parlais justement des néo libéraux
de gauche parce que j'ai l'impression de
lire la leur profession de foi
finalement et leurs critiques par
semaine nintendo wii non mais vous avez
raison hunting tonnes avait une
prescience extraordinaire il avait
d'ailleurs été mal accueillie à l'époque
parce qu'il ne collait pas avec le
catéchisme d'un multiculturalisme qui ne
pouvait que marcher et que ne pouvait
apporter que du bien et lui disait que
les les show culturel perdure et que le
multiculturalisme ne se passe pas
toujours bien pour le moins et parfois
très mal c'est intéressant parce que
quand même c'est un penseur donc
américain et
stratège américain et dans l'esprit par
exemple de beaucoup d'européens en tous
les cas dans les dents dans ce que
l'éducation nationale française souvent
transmet saisissant des états unis en
l'opposant justement au modèle français
on dit un modèle américain qui toujours
le modèle multiculturel serre on aimait
rica en étant multiculturelle là c'est
intéressant puisque c'est un américain
qui critiquent justement cette idée
pourtant tu as fais mais je dis est vrai
c'est que les états unis ont été bâties
sur une multitude d'origine c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais je crois que justement
sur le sac on s'est intéressés d'avoir
ce débat en le mettant dans le contexte
du 11 septembre je crois que samuel
huntington a compris que cette naïveté
de justement des chantres de la
modernisation et de la démocratisation
triomphante qui va avoir raison de tous
les particularismes de tous de toutes
ces choses du passé qui serait que
serait la religion à l'école à la
persistance des cultures etc lui
s'aperçoit et notamment avec le 11
septembre que les choses sont bien plus
compliquées et pendant très longtemps
les américains vont vont refuser même
s'ils partent en guerre
ils vont refuser cette idée vous le
voyez bien par exemple dans la proche
d'obama qu'ils n'approchent de où on va
réconcilier tout le monde il ya quand
même une naïveté qui perdure on peut pas
dire que que on veut pas prononcer le
mot d'islamisme parce qu'on pense que ça
offensé les musulmans et donc on ne
ferait cirque la question de politique
étrangère chez obama qui fait le choix
du soutien aux frères musulmans
notamment on est arrivé au moment de
rêverie exactement des prétoires donc
cette idée que l'on va finalement
s'entendre tous ensemble aussi pas par
la force du symbole que je représente
mois obama je vais pouvoir maintenant
tendre avec eux etc et puis on aimait et
mais je pense qu'au sein de l'amérique
de la société américaine les idées d'un
team tonnes ont au contraire fait leur
chemin et que d'une certaine manière
donald trump s'est aussi je dirais à
retardement aussi une forme de réponse
au 11 septembre c'est à dire que c'est
les américains qu'ils comprennent que le
monde est dangereux que tout ne peut ne
va pas on n'est pas dans le meilleur des
mondes
gentil ou
où on n'a pas d'adversaire mais qu'en
fait on ne doit pas les consignes on ne
pourra pas réconcilier tout le monde
mais on doit défendre notre monde est en
fait ils élisent donald trump justement
en contrepoint je dirais que c'est qui
c'est la réponse à eauze échec d'obama
30 et de ce point de vue là une vision
beaucoup plus un retour au principe de
réalité on va retourner à chaque ville
justement où
est commémorée le crash
provoqué par la révolte des passagers
donc du vol
93 de united airlines
qui empêchait sans doute ce jour-là un
tragédie encore plus grande et on va
vivre ces quelques instants de
commémoration en mémoire et on revient
avec vous juste après leur mobile pour
commenter également ces images et
revenir sur justement les
l'héritage
et ces débats qui ont agité les états
unis
sony corp cyr
[Musique]
à
en termes de gameplay
[Musique]
christine astron weitz gauche
m
[Musique]
voilà donc à chaque évocation à chaque
lecture de nom d'une des
44 victimes de ce crash
on faisait retentir
ses cloches
c'est
la mémoire aux états unis on voit que
c'est quand même quelque chose de
puissant finalement
c'était intéressant d'entendre adrien
jaulmes tout à l'heure et également il
le dit dans son reportage new york
aujourd'hui le mémorial
du 11 septembre gaudette ground zero est
l'une des destinations principales des
touristes à new york oui c'est vrai que
c'est un lieu absolument extraordinaire
moi je les visite est aussi il est
extrêmement émouvant et c'est vrai que
pour les américains quand ils sortent de
l'art je me souviens en avoir avoir
parlé avec les gens qui sortaient du
musée ils sont sous le choc c'est une un
retour sur une page de leur histoire qui
effectivement est gravé dans la psyché
collective des états unis et
marc la laisse une marque indélébile
aussi à cause de de cette forme de
pessimisme on dit souvent que les états
unis c'est un pays optimiste qui va de
l'avant mais je crois que on n'est pas
dans un moment optimiste aujourd'hui
vingt ans plus tard et que le sentinel
va avoir entendu dominique reynié tout à
l'heure qui dit qu' on est était que les
attentats islamistes n'ont jamais été
aussi nombreux et aussi et suivait une
tendance aussi
exponentielle qui l'a tué et donc pour
cette raison là mais aussi pour la
raison de caisse que nous en tant qu
occident on doit faire
d'ailleurs je crois que l'occident est
dans est dans un moment de
questionnement et d'angoua sur quelle
est sa place dans ce monde où justement
comme vous dites il ya sept cette
résurgence cette persistance de de cette
haine anti occidental comment on doit se
positionner est-ce qu'on doit tous ces
débats qui traversent la société
américaine est aussi la société
européenne est ce qu'on doit se replier
sur notre monde pour le protéger est ce
qu'on doit continuer à porter nos
valeurs de quelle manière
et tous et le dialogue qu'il ya ou
plutôt l'absence de dialogue je dirais
mais là c'est plutôt un dialogue
d'imprécations de cris qu'on voit
aujourd'hui entre les deux amériques
l'une qui dit
vous êtes d'une naïveté incroyable vous
voulez finalement
détruire ce qui fait les fondements de
notre pays il faut retrouver le
patriotisme tous attachés à notre à
notre à ce qu'on est en être fier donc
ça c'est le je dirais un peu le camp
républicain entre en piste et puis
l'autre camp qui dit mais non mais on a
fait tellement d'erreurs il faut qu'on
déconstruisent notre monde il faut qu'on
se repentent c'est cette espèce de de
deux crises de culpabilité dont par le
djia mitchell avec beaucoup de de
grandir de brio que j'ai interrogés dont
on parlait au début de l'émission qui
est dans le figaro de vendredi donc donc
il y à il ya en fait ces deux
sets cette interrogation qui traverse en
fait la société qui traversait deux
camps et oui c'est un moment un moment
sombre pour l'occident est un moment de
fragilité de on perçoit notre fragilité
donc on se souvient de ceux de ce moment
de houla où l'amérique a montré sa
vulnérabilité
mais en prenant en compte la fragilité
actuelle voilà il ya en vous écoutant et
en justement en évoquant tout à l'heure
les écrits de samuel huntington
finalement
une question qui vient c'est que
les amériques l'amérique en réalité si
on suit washington c'est aussi un modèle
assimilationniste sert que pour être
américain il faut accepter de renoncer à
ses origines et ça c'est vrai que ce
n'est peut-être pas quelque chose
d'évident pour
d'aidé européen quand on perçoit
justement le communautarisme américains
notamment de la ville new york où il ya
le quartier italien le le quartier
jamaïcain etc etc et en réalité il ya eu
peut-être une erreur de perspective par
rapport à ça et en réalité il faut
renoncer à ses origines pour être
america il n'y a pas de secret c'est le
modèle assimilationniste jeu le modèle
français oui alors c'est pas m je ne
dirais pas que c'est pas exactement le
même modèle c'est à dire qu' il n'y a
pas nécessairement une renonciation
totale à ses origines il se vante
suffisamment de ça donc si vous voulez 7
mai ya le melting-pot pourquoi on
parlait de melting-pot
jadis de l'idée de melting vous avez
raison d'une certaine manière il ya
fusion c'est à dire on se
fait corps avec les irlandais puis en
égrenant totalement il en
reste six irlandais mais on est
américain avant tout est donc ce qui
implique une acceptation de du
fonctionnement de cette nation qui est
avant tout une nation idée est une
nation de citoyens qui deviennent égaux
devant la loi et qu'ils se soumettent
malgré toutes les difficultés que cela a
au travail laborieux des désaccords des
conflits et essai et c'est en en se
confrontant les uns aux autres on arrive
à trouver le consensus ça c'est
l'amérique tocqueville yen qui a prévalu
et celle que huntington reconnaît aussi
et puis vous avez peu à peu le
melting-pot est devenu le la mosaïque
finalement l'amérique mosaïque où
on échoue finalement on a accepté une
idée d'une amérique multiculture d'un
multiculturalisme de juxtaposition des
cultures ou peu où il ya eu par exemple
où il ya peu à peu des revendications de
plus en plus importante sur le maintien
de la culture d'origine et vous avez ça
notamment dans certains groupes de
latinos qui revendique de parler
seulement espagnol ou qui veulent qu'on
inclut
réécrivent l'histoire américaine d'une
certaine manière et c est donc c'est
vrai que peu à peu il ya dès qu'il ya eu
des questionnements et sur comment on
intègre c'est un tâtonnement en fait y'a
pas de ya pas de réponse mais c'est vrai
que huntington était venue dire
attention il ya un substrat et on doit
se couler dans le substrat politique en
fait que nous ont légué qui nous a été
léguée en gros par le modèle britannique
anglais au départ
et avec toute la culture politique que
ça implique démocratique et le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez une
nouvelle idéologie qui a surgi notamment
sur la gauche de l'échiquier politique
cette fameuse deux idéologies wac qui
veut transformer le modèle politique
américain et qui dit qu'aujourd'hui on
ne doit plus considérer que l'amérique
est une nation de citoyens mais une
nation deux groupes qui sont définies
par leur qualité de victime ou de
d'agresseurs c'est ce que dit josh et
mitchell et mais c'est pas seulement lui
qu'il dit c'est cette idéologie et donc
on doit organiser la société en fonction
de ce degré d'innocence ou de
culpabilité et donc ça c'est quand même
extrêmement dangereux de ce que ça m'est
complètement en cause le modèle est bien
sûr la conversation heureusement n'est
pas terminée et on verra comment
cette bataille idéologique extrêmement
apr va pas changer ou non l'amérique
dans les années qui viennent on va jeter
un coup d'oeil à ce qui se passe
actuellement près de pittsburgh en
pennsylvanie où
qui est cette cérémonie qui commémore la
le crash donc du vol de united airlines
du vol 93 suite à la révolte des 44
passagers évitant ainsi une tragédie
plus forte plus grand plus sanglante le
11 septembre
2001 je vous propose d'écouter également
un témoignage le témoignage d'un
français il n'était pas lui dans la dans
l'avion mais il était dans la tour nord
du world trade center et il était dans
ses bureaux quand le premier avion a
percuté cette tour nord son témoignage
est à écouter en intégralité bien sûr
sur le fil sur figaro life mais je vous
propose d'en écouter quelques extraits
à ce moment j'ai commencé à prendre mes
emails et au moment où je prenais où je
téléchargeais mes emails j'ai entendu le
bruit des réacteurs de l'avion qui qui
approchait sur ma façade puisque j'étais
au 47e étage de la tour numéro 1 mais
sur la façade nord donc j'ai bien vu à
un moment je viens été attiré par le
bruit strident de ses réacteurs
j'ai levé la tête il était là et boum
voilà donc
immédiatement tout s'est enchaîné dans
une
truc infernal puisque les façades sont
tombés devant nos yeux médusés et puis
ensuite
le bâtiment semira aussi les deux
manières tanguay manière très
inquiétante
on avait l'habitude en hiver d'entendre
les haubans craquer quand il y avait du
vent mais là on les sentait proche de la
rupture
deux minutes plus tard il ya une mon
adjoint m qui est arrivé dans mon bureau
j'ai encore du late mur par les épaules
tellement le bâtiment tanguay donc ça
vous donne une idée de la violence de
l'impact quand je sortirai un petit peu
plus tard les portes des ascenseurs qui
étaient vitaux annoncé non c'est dans
ces bâtiments c'était des portes
blindées et passe comme ça elles étaient
tordues par la flexion du bâtiment mais
explosé en ça vous donne une idée de la
des puissances qui ont été et les forces
qui ont été
développées leurs enfants pendant
l'impact voilà donc le bureau lui il
était relativement bon état il y avait
des oeuvres d'art qui était tombée des
choses qui étaient tombés d
voilà bon peu importe les la plupart des
dalles de plafond était resté en place
en revanche quand on ouvrait la porte et
c'est ce qu'ont fait nos employés
là il en vue des gens partiront hurlant
parce que c'était des rescapés de 93 et
là il y avait c'était déjà dévastée
parce que il y avait des dalles de
plafond qui s'était explorer qui s'est
écrasé il y avait des fluides qui
tombait il y avait de la fumée aussitôt
après l'impact
donc mes employés sont partis et moi je
suis resté je crois une vingtaine de
minutes sans aucune inquiétude à faire
des sauvegardes informatiques et en me
disant que ça ressemblait fort à ce qui
s'était passé en 45 une histoire que
tous les new yorkais connaissent et un
bombardier qui s'est écrasé sur l'empiré
state building n'ont pas les state
building est toujours là et et
l'histoire me l'a pas retenue voilà bon
donc j'ai pas eu d'inquiétude j'ai
continué à répondre au téléphone faire
des sauvegardes et ainsi de suite puis
au bout d'un moment et cela la main de
dieu je n'en sais rien mais enfin j'ai
alors que je n'avais aucune inquiétude
le message impérieux de partir impériaux
intérieur est impérieux et j'ai obéi
tout simplement alors j'ai mis mon
portable dans un tiroir convaincu que je
reviendrai pour reprendre les nécessités
de mon travail
et
j'ai fermé le bureau je me rappelle très
bien de la fermeture de son bureau et de
la vue une dernière fois et puis je me
suis engagé dans les couloirs où là il y
avait beaucoup de dévastation ce stade
là
non seulement des choses écroulé des
plafonds des choses comme ça mais
surtout on voyait plus rien à me filer
beaucoup de fumée et beaucoup de fluides
et à ce moment là il ya eu un groupe de
personnes qui évacuent en même temps que
moi et pour vous dire combien vraiment
j'ai eu de la chance en réalité ces gens
sont décédées et moi je suis sorti la
différence étant que ont pris un
escalier différent du mien
j'ai été tenté de les suivre
je ne les jeux ne l'ait pas fait parce
qu'on m'avait appris lors des
entraînements qu'on recevait à prendre
un autre escalier pour ma société et
j'ai suivi de les règles tout simplement
et le témoignage est à retrouver en
intégralité il est dans la même veine du
même tenant sur figaro live et vous
l'avez dans le chat qui est juste à côté
sur le site du figaro à côté de ce
player
il est temps de conclure alors merci
beaucoup d'avoir et eric nous dans
l'édito du figaro aujourd'hui philippe
gelie un directeur adjoint du figaro est
en charge de l'international écrit en 20
ans nous avons appris que nos sociétés
sont assez puissantes pour affronter le
virus islamistes à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur pour peu pour tous quelques
pour peu qu'elles acceptent le combat
nous seules défaites sont celles que
nous infligeons à nous mêmes par
faiblesse ou par inconstance je crois
que c'est le pape pie xii qui disait le
règne de satan
réside dans la lâcheté la paresse des
bons finalement est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que dit philippe et
surtout avec eux puisque vous disiez que
c'était assez sombre comme ambiance
aujourd'hui pour commémorer ses 20 ans
est-ce que
l'occident en particulier la france
également où les états unis ont les
moyens justement de gagner cette guerre
qui a été déclenchée par ces attentats
il ya vingt ans maintenant mais je crois
que cette guerre est elle se joue
effectivement comme le dit philippe
gelie chez nous dans nos murs puisque en
particulier pour pour la france
il faut beaucoup de courage
effectivement et je pense que c'est un
ça devient une des qualités je dirais
essentiel de l'homme politique
aujourd'hui et du citoyen français c'est
le courage mais je dirais aussi le
discernement le discernement c'est à
dire la volonté de voir ce qu'il faut
voir comme dirait pierre manent parce
que pendant longtemps on n'a pas voulu
voir ce qu'on dit ce que l'on voyait et
je crois qu'il faut
à la fois
voir la réalité des dangers qui sont
extrêmement importants je pense que
cette bataille est compliqué parce que
justement
une il ya une bataille dans l'islam
nous y avons beaucoup d'alliés au sein
de l'islam et nous y avons aussi des
ennemis qui veulent la destruction de
l'occident est donc là toute la
difficulté c'est comment comment on fait
pour pour protéger notre monde et nos
valeurs de ses ennemis eux qui peuvent
utiliser la démocratie pour la détruire
merci beaucoup lors d'avoir commenté et
donner justement votre éclairage et
votre expérience vos informations aussi
sur ses vingt années qui nous séparent
donc de cet attentat de ces attentats du
11 septembre je signale qu on vous
retrouve sur figaro live dès la fin de
la semaine prochaine pour la troisième
édition des conversations tocqueville
ils sont consacrés au futur de la
démocratie en amérique conférences
tables rondes et interviews à suivre en
direct donc et en replay sur le site du
figaro les attentats islamistes dans le
monde 1979 2010 900 que c'est une étude
à retrouver sur le site de la fondapol
c'est l'étude de référence et puis on en
parlait tout à l'heure à merak
passionnant reportage donc d'adrien
jaulmes sedan les bases américaines
d'irak istin est aussi le livre qu'il a
traduit et préfacé retour de jihadistes
et aux racines de l'état islamique c'est
aux éditions tous les deux de d'équateur
aux éditions des équateurs également qui
est vraiment donald trump que vous avez
signé
leur en a pas on n'a pas signalé mais on
ne le signale jamais assez puisque en
2016 vous êtes l'une des deux
journalistes françaises qui avaient
prédit la possible victoire de donald
trump c'est avec anne toulouse également
merci aux équipes de filles en live au
tour de jean-pierre vanhelder et maxime
kuni mention particulière à ryadh
béquille raphaël lazreg albane bug
virginie le trionnaire sandrine
saudubray et sache avec hermann à la
modération merci beaucoup à vous chers
internautes d'avoir été avec nous cet
après midi pour suivre cette
commémoration historique pour cet
événement qui est également historique
bien sûr on en reparlera puisque comme
le disait alors
les
choses vont continuer la guerre n'est
pas terminée entre l'occident et l'islam
isme bien sûr vous pouvez continuer de
vivre en direct cette journée sur le
site du figaro retrouvez le live des
commémorations le minute par minute de
la journée du 11 septembre 2001 l'aktu
ne prend pas de week-end au figaro nous
on se retrouve en vidéo en direct demain
pour le grand jury à 12 heures